عسكرية في مواقع مدنية. سيرجي
لافروف قال ان هناك مسعى لتوسيع
اربع وعشرين ساعة الجيش الروسي
يعلن عن قصف اربعة مواقع لقيادة
للضحية حد قوله. وكانت المنظمة
قد اصدرت تقريرا اشارت فيه الى
اسيا والناتو يحذر روسيا
والمجنون يشتم رائحة البارود.
على اي فعل متهور بخصوص تايوان
قد يتسبب في ازمة اكبر. الصواريخ
امريكا الى حرب مفتوحة. فهل هذه
المناورات جاءت ردا على تصريحه
ان الجيش الاوكراني يعرض حياة
مدنيين للخطر في انشائه قواعد
يتم الترويج لاشراك اليابان في
خطة التوسيع. وزير الخارجية
وانجي يرفع نبرة التهديدات محذرا
الولايات المتحدة من ان اقدامها
السابق? الاحداث والتطورات.
سرايا القدس تعلن عن قصف
البنية العسكرية للناتو في منطقة
المحيطين الهادئ والهندي وانه
الصينية تفقد سيطرتها وامريكا
تسعى لاستعادة سيطرتها على شرق
على ادارة كبرى ونحن لن نتوقف عن
الدعم الكامل لها. بينما في خلال
الزعيم الكوري. اصوات المدافع
والصواريخ تزعج زعيم كوريا
واستهداف تل ابيب ومطار بنجوريون
واسدود وبئر السبع وعسقلان. قائد
الموت. بريتني جرينر لاعبة السلة
الشهيرة التهمة تهريب المخدرات
الحرس الثوري الايراني ان تطور
امكانات المقاومة يؤكد قدرتها
الجيش الاوكراني وهنا يأتي الرد
من الجانب الاوكراني انه تم قصف
الشمالي. واذا به يصحو على
مناورات عسكرية مع كوريا
الجنوبية حيث كان تدريبا على
اهداف محاكية لاستهداف المواقع
مواقع مدنية ولم يتم استهداف
مواقع عسكرية. اتهم الرئيس
قبضت عليهما السلطات الروسية وقد
اعترفت بريتني جرينر بالتهمة
وافقا على صفقة التبادل هذه
وستتم خلال الايام القادمة. غضب
والمواطنين في العالم. مهلا عندي
سؤال لماذا عندما يغلق بوتين
المناورات بلغت ذروتها على
الحدود وقد تصل رياحها الى كمب
النووية ومخازن التسليح والوقود
في كوريا الشمالية. هذه
ما قد يثير شهية الحرب لديه. هذه
المناورة عرفت باسم سلسلة الموت.
فيما استعرض زعيم كوريا الشمالية
قبل ايام اسلحة النووية ودعا
الموت الروسي. والذي تم الحكم
عليه بالسجن لخمسة وعشرين عاما
صنبور الغاز صراخكم يملأ العالم?
او نية لخرق القوانين اما بول
ويلان فهو مسئول تنفيذي لشركة
عسكري يهدد سوريا. ابن الكريملين
لاعب سياسي ماهر يستطيع ان يعطي
وحكم عليه بالسجن لمدة ستة عشر
عاما. الولايات المتحدة
مثل هذه الخطوة سيكون ساحقا.
وهنا مجموعة سنبحث وحظر نقل
ستولتنبرج بانه يجب عدم السماح
لروسيا ان تنتصر في الحرب. ودعا
ستولتنبرغ دول الناتو الى دعم
اوكرانيا بالاسلحة على المدى
المنسوبة اليها قائلة انا اعترف
بتهم المواجهة لي. وانا اتفهم كل
والتجسس. وهذا الجندي السابق في
البحرية الامريكية اولا جاسوس
امن القي القبض عليه في موسكو في
ديسمبر عام الفين وثمانية عشر
وسنعمل على تخفيف تأثير اضطرابات
الامدادات على الاقتصادات
بقدر ما يأخذ ليأتي الرد من في
الناتو. وعلى لسان يونس
تبعات ان تتجاوز طموحاتها
اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان رد الناتو على
النفط والمنتجات البترولية
الروسية بحرا على مستوى العالم.
الطويل لمنع موسكو من تحقيق
النصر. وحذر ستولتنبرغ روسيا من
الاوكرانيسكي منظمة العفو
الدولية بانها حولت المعتدي
والمتهم بدعم عدة بالسلاح
والتآمر لقتل مسؤولين امريكيين
رفيعي المستوى. وهنا يرد سيرجي
لافروف ان الرئيسين بوتين وبايدن
الامريكية قررت تبادل السجناء مع
روسيا بهذين السجينين مقابل تاجر
الجماعات الارهابية التي ازهقت
ارواح المدنيين الابرياء في
ما يقال ضدي ولهذا السبب انا اقر
بالذنب. وانا لم يكن لي اي ذنب
الفلسطينية بعدة رشقات صاروخية
يقدر عددها الى هذه اللحظة بمائة
الولايات المتحدة تؤيد حق
اسرائيل في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
وسبعون جريحا. الناطق باسم مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي ان
عن السلطات الاسرائيلية ولا عزاء
يوقعون على زواج غير شرعي
في مسعى للتهدئة. وهنا شركة
الطيران الاماراتية فلاي دبي
لطفلة ذات خمسة اعوام
بالارهابية? وهنا ترد المقاومة
والابتسامة الغبية تشق وجوههم.
بوتين وحلف الناتو. حفيد عثمان
والدب الروسي على طاولة واحدة.
بوتين صرح قائلا لن نسمح بعمل
متوقع حيث اعلنت وزارة الدفاع
اليابانية ان خمسة صواريخ
واضاف ان طوكيو قدمت بالفعل
احتجاجا لدى الصين قائلا ان هذه
تلغي رحلة الى تل ابيب. ودعت
سفارة الامارات في تل ابيب
باليستية اطلقتها الصين خلال
عسكري حول تايوان سقطت داخل
عمرها خمس سنوات. وسيدة تبلغ من
العمر ثلاثة وعشرين عاما وخمسة
المنطقة الاقتصادية. وقال وزير
الدفاع الياباني نوبو كيشي ان
اكثر من اربعين موقعا. والنتيجة
استشهاد عشرة من بينهم طفلة
وكذلك ملفات التنسيق العسكري
ليأتي بعدها اعلان ياباني غير
اسرائيل. بحسب تعبيره. الا
تستحون يا ابناء العم سام بوصفكم
مواطنيها الى اخذ الحيطة والحذر
واتباع تعليمات السلامة الصادرة
اطلاق الصواريخ مسألة خطيرة
تتعلق بالامن القومي الياباني.
يترك شي جين بينغ حقك يا كليب.
فلسطين تتألم. ثلاثون غارة على
هي المرة الاولى التي يسقط فيها
صاروخ من الجيش الصيني في المياه
وستين صاروخا. لتعلن مصر ان وفدا
مصريا يستعد للتحرك الى تل ابيب
اليابانية. فعلا لا فقد الصينيون
اعصابهم والسبب هي الباسوس فلن
اهمها التغير المناخي ومكافحة
الاوبئة الصحية ومكافحة المخدرات
دفعات صواريخ باليستية لتعزز
بدفعة جديدة تجاه مناطق متعددة
قبالة تايوان لترد امريكا وتعلن
ان حاملة الطائرات تجري عمليات
بكين بايقاف التعاون مع الولايات
المتحدة في عدد من المجالات
دورية في بحر تايوان بالاضافة
الى سفن حربية بينها مدمرات لترد
كيم ويثلج صدور الصينيين لنعد
الى بكين والتي لم تكتفي بثلاث
وكوريا الشمالية لتكون اقرب لعدة
امتار الزعيم الكوري فهل يفعلها
مع كوريا الشمالية والتي تقع تحت
سيطرة مشتركة من الامم المتحدة
طائراتها على كوريا الجنوبية
لتزور بيلوسي المنطقة الحدودية
تعلن عن بنك اهداف جديد في عمق
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي. وطعنة
ها هي اليوم في اليابان وبجوار
المجنون ولم تكتفي بذلك بل حطت
اماراتية في ظهر المقاومة
الفلسطينية. الباسوس. من
المجنون. بعد اثارة غضب الصين
بسوس العصر لم تتوقف في تايوان.
وامريكا تضع يدها على صيد روسي
ثمين. بينما المقاومة الفلسطينية
عسكري وشيك مع روسيا والسبعة
تتخذ قرارا كارثيا تجاه موسكو.
لن نسمح باي تدخل عسكري في
سوريا. والناتو يحذر من تصادم
لترد امريكا بارسال حاملة طائرات
وسفن حربية قبالة بحر تايواي.
وهنا يأتي رد صيني غير متوقع يضع
الامريكان في موقف محرج. بوتين
الشمالية. فليورنا اهما بجعبته.
صواريخ الصين تتساقط في اليابان.
البسوس اقصد نانسي بيلوسي تعلنها
للعالم. انا ذاهبة لزعيم كوريا
فهل تناوله بسوس العصر مبتغاه
هذه المرة.